plastic polluting our oceans harming
marine life and washing up in remote
corners of the world and today 60 years
of monitoring could unlock decades of
data for scientists although we knew
plastics were increasing getting a
consistent time series together to show
that increase has been very difficult
especially in the open ocean where we
don't have a lot of data and there's
been some microplastic studies that have
shown that increase but they haven't yet
been able to show the increase beyond
the 90s and that's where this study is
different it does show that increase in
the past the only way of monitoring
macro plastics like bottles or bags in
the sea would be by chance encounters
with marine life entangled in it but
researchers at the University of
Plymouth have been looking at data from
this machine which mimics the movement
of marine life it's been towed behind
ships collecting plankton since the
1930s but as its towed plastics have
come into contact with it which is
allowed scientists to look at 60 years
of data over 6.5 million
nautical miles and the data shown a
three-fold increase from 1% to 3% in the
amount of plastic that was captured in
the North Atlantic
just days ago the president of the
Seychelles made history with an
underwater message to the world it is
clear to me that it is under threat like
never before a call for help from a
country he says has been the victim of
global neglect
this research confirms what we suspected
the link between increasing plastic
production and plastic waste in the
ocean the report recommends sustainable
solutions to packaging and increasingly
firms are realizing there's money to be
made by finding an environmentally
friendly alternative companies have to
have a green policy today it's an
absolute essential for the future
survival and prosperity of any company
today most consumers today want to know
how the pack is disposed of and with
these adverse impact on the environment
the hope is this new research will be
able to unlock the scale of pollution
around the world a long-term dataset
that's been virtually non-existent until
now a solution though will take longer
Alley Fortescue Sky News